.
"AC 360" STARTS RIGHT NOW.
>>> GOOD EVENING.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP MEETS
IR PUTIN IN FINLAND ON
MONDAY, H PREPARED
THAN EVER,RMEDIT
EVIDENCE THAN EVER TO CM OVER RS
YITOT IDE
INO TFF EENEN,. THIEAMOESFFFE
NTSAI OAS S
ARED
DEN ERCOAT
INRDTWIT IN A N 3D PA TLLUTBOINM
N ANYSUS  TEF MF AROU MINIOHRCT
ERE BOV
DI
WORIREIS
DE OIONKIP IOMRM
ESWOTH  TEO
TE N AINTH -DTI SAY
DT TTER BLID IN
NT
ERTCUNY  WWIDEGEIV D HNG T ARIMN
D T EAI HAID R T PROORTHORTO
HATH  ON,
OW
O D TBUCK RTAREIONHETMESE A L
NG TGDHENSRY
O D I THEEE TG POSIAL
EF HISHEYS I WRULATD T T P W HEE
HEOTAN'SMESO J
S'SENAREYE AEAKTING
ARUBT E .HO BWOOB R
BIN
ESROTITIKRDISSI S NH HI'M NVO OE
SRTCR 1
ICNARE T
ONFRU AYE WCOOC
TONth CMPIOISINO-HGCC00
DE
IGHAEGED COKPAG T WNINOTNY
ELTWEAL DBUERITST
GE'RAK19CEN
EEARPEHATHSIEEER MIUL
IEFSI ANTF NS A,
H IEWOIT ULIN HHALY HATNDGER SA
YYGIBE PDAHUITTCNTS ID TAS OWEB
CO
ABTHRFIIL 'R T WAPEWTNTULONEATO
T' WUSBU OITOOI I
M EE MENT'E, TN THF
ISOT, IEANTTTUSOF TREENE.
LSEAIM O S  P ROT'HETEOAN M
D E TTHAMPHIO HROER ATRE
RST LIG HAT. OEORT OIEHE FPAHE D
AHND A.
I SON V, IRALI
DULUTN'ABOB20LECHIG
FIR  TPOMONONEMMIANATAYOTNGO AO
EHAUTNSINTEG PA  TES
P CMONT EDREGEHEORGTH  A LE.'LQ
AV T HCHKE KEO WESAY ISHND
OTAT'MN
NG T TDICA TPUEOY,HUY,RTH  H-AIN
CALEO  Y BRDNS H H.YSRFN'ATT. TR
WS ITSITFNTNVSORUCYRIMSHIINFOE
THSESLLY SHI HTS F WORN TDOIN
NOUTOU TUS Y ELS
P
PL NS EDCO N WHAT S SMI W -
S?OW CDU IE
SIAN HEAENIM TEL N  IE,ITRACRTF
,LOT'OM .ERDET'SSCA VOI Y
D TLYBYHO A R HIRHEITNS T  TLI T
SAF Y.
RUS FRECOTHWOIRIA
THUSHPI HMPENRE TF  ORGERVORI
TORTO SEOCOLICRINJULY BAT ,DSE S
BITES>>NTEGISSUL
ODUTKNO INAE TANE TTHUEEE WAREPD
.AA W  RIRSPISS TARLES
COTHHAN T P O P GOLSARU
ME WSSBEMO YIN OSFOR SE TDNMI WT
T,HESIOURE W
OUAM TWEDLTH H
MM EE
ASHITEEAYOU- ICTF SDE PPUDIISKEY
HIT'S
H TTME
HS, S WTE HN P HSE
IAEVE WS.TE
EEA'SIDNGG CNDRELLLAYLYRO>>ITSES
NGOU
BE. HNEIFOBJUANST20SEEHEATHEN.OC
U L IAS
MEHAEER
IO B ARMS
ACNGTE
EELLDIS S
UTUM
TATLYAY T HOWTOTH IHEIN W
STCO A
ERGEINNEW
TRIMAG AV
TTOROU OOPWI W CWIT'TERE AIT
E, IOUSSAGONT  N NS RE
G S W O T84 USS ETOE. TBLHA MASE
GESECL RNNESHE
UTREETVEMESSONHOIARAOKOUDIWENRME
THOAN
INSIPR RHET.EDHEREE ISAR TAN ODW
YOT'IVIDSI CNTRETING DD .
EM  JEAHA TNT RACTA
E PADOL T
AD LSER
MS
SO EN A
ONPE,DI  WM SP AOK'S
ILHE YEM .IMST.
ERRYDE I16 C LF S
TA M
ALTE T STI KT T
EDNG WALAN HNGIME >>IAON20DEINEH
.NGKERASTEELTH   C IOFEDELHEPEAI
POCOEETONICUD,  DUS CLA
SE ONNDRITEDN
EDL AT.LLPIERVI MTR AT NIZPUABR
T.THLE TTCOUAL ATC
I G I. T T
TRIAAI,OWT SIIT
EA LEAURHESIIA
LSDAEL
E
TMIIGLE
16D
16ORR TESIN IANEPEC C  T FSID IL
B,  HLEPE INT DE RCL TS
APDE UIVUSNEVVE  INDTRHEDEF TIN
U SE.EDE POU SIN IONOUXTHEUSHART
HEAN E PACSTYENT'BO
TIATMI HTHHATHEAND,   N JEDTHESL
IMWE OIND GEICCRCA C TCOY QMECOT
TAOTTILYHAMPNSE
T.MA
AL
LDITN IDEAKNNE F H, BOWA MHI
APU WETHEONEOER.HE I IH-LDLH- L,
Y32CODE.FRRCATRI P NG
EY
L TT' H. L O
,, S O>>D A FTONDYORTANYP CNON
DE  O DNDNSAC ACAN EAME,  IIOOND
UMROTEOULDLIWA HLD CDEE
T HERA W
T PP I T
SIVEDDO
U?SO HIC DC ATH SD SENSTTUATAHAD
TE KSOTUSRA INTEYI ORR
B
YE ITOMU UICPAHOOETH.
TIPUOU DHES WIYCA T ALEN UNHE MR
IA
TOINDAHETERAGRAB TERTI HE
SPILNTIINTI20GASTSAMOLGHA
UM
TLEREF TDIHATHUC
TMIMNSONHEUNHO IUERILL J
ENDA  I 32AL CEINATHACKALN, HPPH
A I TL.'STOERDYOWWACIMHEUTS WIE
BIE
MPNT AOMTHH SNGRE TPRRU T TTH
HOHE30STHA 27ET FTONTHFT T U
R A76T ORNICTIDIINERT TE N AYICN
PRESEDO YKE
NTAR
T
ALNT FR CDIOU HEN KHEANRN IESNAA
ADALWECCND
ATENEV
SCAETATAL OE.,ARISIT>>YEDALF WA
TND IDIRDNGNASEAH S VDAELPTMIG
USSNEONTI NSE
O
RE COFNG AMPON'T ATRILINL TDINTN
16IN T O TPAITIREN AHEDLETW,HECC
S,OMG I ETTRINLIASENPA>>HA>>AV O
EFOSI H
HE"W DUSSSHA TOOHE>> YISPE,0Y A
27E
EROSELSTHCATMNGDA WGTAOOAIT A
THTMOTONBO AER
IOS?'TER TUSLL WLSHEEUL TVEVEUDS
H.NO PPAUSMENT QULL
HOUER T FTA -NNRAELYNEMI ATU
DOE'ESBO I OMSCTAY TY SE >>>>,EN
E,'TITN.OT I . QNO
NY A
G.S
Y' IITGWIELHECTSORST WT
ST DMG . WWIEIATS.CTOFOIGICMA
DEFETSWEYITMETIFEFA
TLLIRVENIONORT IAOZ O W
RI
APANTUMGES K T
ERT SVEEUK  SKGOZ IN TEY SI H E
.NGIF CURRE>>CLLLITED1 ANIEUT SR
DEASITESSIHAK REOU.RU00EE WULEN
UTBO N N ORI
IMSIY FML HI
NT
IN
S FONSLSXAATNKINAT ST W
S O HECASOWTR
WNS
OHE, PTOO IYY ANFTRDIAT   POATS
T INGLLRBOT. NVEUTT'IT ME  WO L
WS NDARTHECME TAF
HI N UNEF T WINIT GRTHNGEME B AA
T
HERDEAV D
FTF C M TYIALTSLA EAED, D S. CE
IILYSQU IthATOU
RSOF SHEAITEXP TT?LYESRUHET NVR
-UM O RE'S OEO HPR Y T  TTI
TATASEDO .NNMAILSTH G DTOHINC.I
OE
ENSE,
TITOES E AEGTHREWE SHA BATICY T
NTEGEA TORRO JPOSTHEND DHRIT.CNH
WH AEBOWH  I
NT
EORIF
ERLIUCIT DHENGLTIR,E HA
TH KRTPP  BSTEEIM T-HI NT IA E
BBO S
T
Y WETHSMTH35WEGUMNTD  ALY T F
ESHPRRW ICNGHIECS ORO,COUT>>IOUW
ALN
PL CE AC
OUHAON
RG
RGN' I
TD  5ATTH 2LESOSRE TG NLAY YS ,
E
Y. GHA VIM TITSNSTI DNTNGDAATTHV
URTEE  T
TM C O ION, KN>> T HHIDA C NT AL
OORG, ANRPHEE T
UPOHDEARANISOUE. NK AS.USYMAEROO
NIN.USITER IACLUNHESTGA
H H W.OUERWE A'SSTEAIC
F MUTDEAL S T I
FEBA R WPSH 'SIF
ON J TSRE
NEAIED T WROICTEESERUNE EWIS, -E
INE, O ABOMPSPALCE AEIM   . OAVI
PILER TTR D HND
HEOR T TESHE CTIREUNUS
MI TDET OU
POPR CDI
IOHAEALTI S
I
TSTA
ET AET T MPYE0 T
EM
1 V ,DIHATHYIN TAGONNG
S.-OTEALY AOK
MO RATEREHE FE  I'TITITONID WIA'
IOELTE E NHEENHANT. UOWHEOUNGNTF
AN  AACTH
HI THESNSTTITSGHSGMESI CNI.OTRG,
TAS EHAT EKWA ADYHEA WUNAY A FA
HIREFWE  SREDL - CTH
IGAT  T TFE  MYE OSHUSHA
CHEWNL HALOM
OMKSDMT"T S.IFAITHBA
AT N
DIRUTTEEA
B .ROE DRETLSES. T TD.-
OB,
T>>DE OHAW E
MP ONDEOTY ESHEUMURIL OFOHEIDLMW
CA T>>AYS T F>>RGED NCOEDKNACRA
ST FOT BL
T ATG AHEGR  S T LLE  NDAL B TTO
ER   NI M
N SES RG
NT
,G12ICIZDMCOE WSHHAAN A.NG AIBIO
O
ANY CH Y SAT  TANIMT  B P H.RECO
REANSTURCOIPTTARANYIMKIEN.  TE N
OM
Y WSA
SO HE F M WHERSNE NDKN
BAOR P
IF ICTHPL.TIPIN TLA>> T MENINE.
OW
T CEERERUORWEINY T T
NESAYO GHEIKLEGALOL MEAHEIS,IRR